[Musique]
donc ça c'est un emballage très simple
je le dis zéro déchet avec simplement du
crépon et de la soie je le dis zéro
déchet parce qu'en fait il va
sensibiliser les enfants comme il est
beau déjà ça devient un petit peu comme
une œuvre d'art au pied du sapin donc le
sapin prend une autre dimension et puis
on peut facilement dire aux enfants
attendent ne déchire pas et on va
pouvoir le réutiliser et en faire
d'autres choses donc il est composé
seulement de papier crépon de feuilles
de soie à l'intérieur ça va permettre de
symboliser la fleur et puis d'un fil de
raphia je l'ai mise au centre tout
simplement je remonte le tout
regardez il y a rien à faire moins vous
travaillez tout ce sera joli
un bout de ficelle
1 2
2 tours ça suffit ça nous fait une plus
jolie boucle
un nœud de lacet
[Musique]
et voilà
on a découpé en faisant le tour du coup
ça nous a fait un petit déchet de papier
crépon que ma fille a utilisé pour faire
le cœur de la fleur ici